swear your oath
moraine's to die
i swear to speak no word that is not
true
to make no weapon with which one person
may kill another
and never to use the one power as a
weapon
do you know what i see means in the old
town
servants of all
[Music]
it is they who serve the world
i didn't choose this path but i will
follow it
where next the two rivers
the old blood runs deep in those
mountains
let's hope it's prepared then for what's
coming
the dark one is waking
but there will be one who can stand
against him
and it's one of the five of you
you fully lost your mind
your life isn't going to be what you
thought
what are those
his army is coming
what can we
do we protect the people we love
no matter the cost
our enemies are everywhere
they will leave no one standing
we've lost too many people already back
home
[Music]
you won't
if we do not stop the dark one now
the whole world will burn
i can't allow it
the wheel weaves as the wheel wills
do you think we'll ever go back
home
no
you